Looking to January, comparable sales are expected to be negative...
...due in part to the shift in Chinese New Year...
...and consumer perception issues in Japan.
The changes we're making are designed to refocus our system on those areas...
...that matter most to our customers today and for the future.
And that starts with deepening our relationship with customers...
...to increase relevance, drive traffic...
...and position McDonald's for longer-term growth.
At the same time, we're strengthening the menu pipeline...
...to create greater choice at the local levels...
...that reflect attributes like taste preferences and demographics...
...and those things that make each market unique.
You'll also see changes in our customer service models...
...as we work to create more memorable experiences...
...and to deliver unparalleled convenience.
We're also strengthening the value proposition.
We're strategically evaluating pricing relationships across the entry-level,...
...core and premium tiers of our menu.
At the same time, we're thinking differently about how to encourage customers...
...to bundle products and use add-on purchases...
...to create a satisfying, affordable meal.
Collectively, these changes create the McDonald's experience of the future,...
...which brings the work that's happening within each strategic priority together...
...to deliver changes our customers will notice.
It builds on the investments we've already made in technology,...
...reimaging our restaurants and operations improvement...
...with an increased emphasis on tangible customer-centric innovations...
...for menu and service to profitably grow the business.